[Musique]
le premier ministre est monté à la
tribune avec un discours de 22 pages qui
a duré environ une heure il était en
costume gris foncé et chemise blanche et
cravate noire il a lu ce texte sur un
ton mesuré est ferme et il a été écouté
dans avec beaucoup d'attention par tous
les parlementaires et certains passages
de ses déclarations ont suscité des
rumeurs mais extrêmement légère sur les
bancs de l'opposition lorsqu'il
s'agissait des critiques delà du rôle
par exemple de l'état et de
l'administration
le premier ministre a donné un caractère
solennel à sa déclaration puisque vous
savez qu'il a engagé la responsabilité
du gouvernement il a en quelque sorte
poser la question de confiance et je
voudrais faire remarquer que c'est une
procédure solennelle dans la mesure où
c'est seulement la cinquième fois
qu'elle est utilisée depuis dix ans très
exactement depuis 1959
dès le début de sa déclaration monsieur
chaban delmas avait déclaré il faut
faire de la france avant tout une
puissance industrielle moderne
il énumère ensuite les freins qui ont
empêché ce développement et son analyse
du comportement de l'état depuis 25 ans
est extrêmement critique il parle même
de déformation et de malfaçons de cette
société bloquée je retiens trois
éléments essentiels au demeurant liés
les uns aux autres de la façon la plus
étroite
la fragilité de notre économie le
fonctionnement souvent défectueux de
l'état enfin l'archaïsme et le
conservatisme de nos structures sociales
notre économie est encore fragile une
preuve en est que nous ne pouvons
accéder au plein emploi sans tomber dans
l'inflation
c'est cette tendance à l'inflation qui
nous menacent en permanence d'avoir à
subir la récession ou la dépendance
tentaculaire et en même temps
inefficaces
voilà nous le savons ce qui est en passe
de devenir l'état et cela en dépit de
l'existence d'un corps de fonctionnaires
très généralement compétents et parfois
remarquables
nous sommes encore un pays de casse des
écarts excessifs de revenus une mobilité
sociale insuffisante maintiennent des
cloisons anachronique entre les groupes
sociaux des préjugés aussi par exemple
dans une certaine catégorie de la
population d'un ouvrière à l'encontre
des métiers techniques ou manuel ce
tableau a été volontairement brossé en
couleur sombre
je le crois nécessaire comme je crois
aussi que les français sont aujourd'hui
en état de considérer et d'en tirer les
leçons
c'est aussi parce que j'ai la conviction
que nous entrons dans une époque
nouvelle ou de grands changements sont
possibles et qu en accord avec le
président de la république avec le
gouvernement tout entier et je l'espère
avec votre appui et votre soutien
j'ai la volonté d'entreprendre ces
grands changements
le premier ministre prévoit rétabli en
quelque sorte ce constat ou si vous
aimez mieux ce diagnostic reconnaît que
la france a des excuses car elle a dû
affronter en 20 ans toutes les mutations
toutes les transformations à la fois et
notamment l'ouverture de ses frontières
maintenant dit il faut s'engager
résolument sur la voie du changement
il faut construire une nouvelle société
elle devra être prospère jeunes
généreuse et libre voici comment il voit
cet avenir pourquoi notre société
nouvelle aura tout d'abord le visage de
la jeunesse la vague démographique des
25 dernières années nous offre une
chance unique de rajeunissement en août
l'éclosion des talents est souvent plus
précoce aujourd'hui qu'il ya un siècle
comment refuserions nous au nom de
principes caduque et en nous accrochant
à les structures périmés d'offrir à
notre jeunesse
une participation pleine et entière
à la construction de l'avenir de son
avenir
le gouvernement envisage que la
politique de formation et d'enseignement
est prioritaire lorsque vous
examineraient le projet de budget pour
1970 vous constaterez que les crédits de
l'éducation nationale augmente deux fois
plus vite que l'ensemble des dépenses
budgétaires
mais il ne suffit pas de former des
hommes il faut aussi les informer
complètement c'est-à-dire
contradictoirement ceci concerne d'abord
le rtf qui doit conserver son caractère
de service public garant de la qualité
de l'ensemble des programmes mais pour
qu'il puisse répondre pleinement à sa
vocation son autonomie doit être assurée
une compétition véritable doit être
organisé en son sein et il doit être
ouvert à tous enfin
[Applaudissements]
et il faut que le fils soit également
ouvert à tous et dans ce but
j'ai demandé de prévoir des modalités et
des temps d'antenne pour que puisse
s'exprimer régulièrement toutes les
formations politiques et les
organisations socio professionnelles
nationales
le chef du gouvernement en vient à la
redéfinition du rôle de l'état sa
réforme en quelque sorte
je crois que l'on peut dire qu'à travers
tout son exposé il a défini un nouvel
esprit aussi bien en ce qui concerne les
rapports entre l'état et
l'administration qu'au sein même du
corps social il s'agit il là dit d'un
changement de mentalité
l'état doit faire son métier at il dit
mais pas celui des autres
il indique par ailleurs que des études
sont en cours pour supprimer les doubles
emplois et l'émission inutile les
ministres ont dans un premier temps
trois mois pour proposer la
réorganisation de leur administration
un corps volant mobile de
l'administration va faire tâche
désormais aux tâches urgentes et aux
missions nouvelles ce qui permettra de
supprimer des missions permanentes des
commissions permanentes
enfin le taux de croissance des dépenses
budgétaires sera inférieur à celui de la
production nationale est désormais dans
le budget de 70 le premier ministre
traite ensuite du troisième objectif
l'amélioration de la compétitivité de
l'économie
en ce qui concerne les bases du
développement est tout d'abord l'emploi
et la formation professionnelle le
gouvernement accélérera la mise en
oeuvre d'une politique dynamique au
service de la promotion des travailleurs
nous avons libéré par anticipation une
fraction du contingent nous envisageons
de poursuivre cette politique pour la
fraction suivante
le parlement sera saisi pour en stopper
sa session de printemps d'une nouvelle
loi ramenant la durée du service
militaire à 12 mois
[Applaudissements]
300 km d'autoroute au moins seront mises
en chantier en 1970 soit plus du double
de cette année et de nouvelles modalités
de financement permettront d'atteindre
ce rythme élevé de développement de
notre réseau
la progression des investissements
consacrés au téléphone dépassera 40 % en
1970 cet effort sera poursuivi au cours
des années suivantes il rendra possible
une baisse importante des prix
d'installation
il sera accompagné d'un assouplissement
des structures de notre administration
des postes et télécommunications ainsi
en 1973
nous ferons plus que doubler le trafic
qui a été écoulée en 1968
s'agissant du développement industriel
les mécanismes de financement et de
restructuration seront complétés et même
transformé par la création de l'institut
de développement industriel organismes
léger destiné à prendre des
participations en fonds propres
temporaires dont la présidence sera
confiée à une personnalité venant du
secteur privé dont la gestion sera
assurée suivant les modalités du droit
privé et qui ne sera ni une banque
d'état ni un hospice pour entreprises
menacées
parmi les autres mesures pour favoriser
le développement industriel il faut
également citer un site des incitations
fiscales ou des facilités de crédit pour
les exportateurs et pour les entreprises
qui par exemple étalons les vacances en
accord bien sûr avec leur personnel pour
l'agriculture définition également d'une
nouvelle politique développement d'une
agriculture de compétition mais
parallèlement aide aux personnes + co
production excédentaires sur des bases
ainsi renforcé a poursuivi monsieur
chaban delmas nous devrons rajeunir dans
chaque secteur les structures et les
mécanismes
il implique précise le chef du
gouvernement cette décision implique
pardon imprécise le chef du gouvernement
la transformation des relations
professionnelles la revalorisation de la
condition ouvrière et une redéfinition
de la solidarité
monsieur chaban-delmas parle notamment
de l'établissement du salaire mensuel et
du temps du travail est également d'une
réforme de l'allocation de salaire
unique elle sera augmentée pour les
familles aux revenus modestes mais
réduite et parfois supprimés selon le
niveau de vie des bénéficiaires il
poursuit j'ai déjà dit l'importance que
le gouvernement attache à la
transformation des relations
professionnelles
à cette fin il propose tout d'abord au
patronat et aux syndicats de coopérer
avec l'état pour des tâches d'intérêt
commun c'est ainsi que peut être
envisagée qu'une gestion tripartite des
services de l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle dans les entreprises
nationales de nouvelles procédures de
détermination des salaires seront
étudiés en liaison avec les
organisations syndicales et pourront
être appliquées dès les années 1970
elles permettront d'intéresser les
travailleurs du secteur public à la fois
aux fruits de l'expansion nationale et
au progrès spécifiques de chaque
entreprise
ainsi pourront être discutés conclu par
entreprise des contrats de progrès
pluriannuels portant notamment sur
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
ainsi que sur les modalités destinée à
assurer le bon fonctionnement et la
continuité du service public
le gouvernement s'attachera par priorité
à la revalorisation des bas salaires
d'une part adoption concertée d'un
nouveau régime pour le smig
d'autre part programme pluriannuel en
faveur des petites catégories de la
fonction publique
tels sont mesdames et messieurs les
grandes lignes de l'action
que le gouvernement compte menée avec
rigueur et obstination rien ne sera
facile certes et rien ne sera possible
sans un effort de travail et d'epargne
de tous dans l'immédiat les mesures
prises doivent nous permettre de limiter
à quelques mois la phase d'austérité
d'ailleurs toute relative et de
retrouver des bases économiques saines
qui peut contester que tout écart par
rapport à la rigueur nécessaire
prolongerait inutilement et
dangereusement les déséquilibres actuels
et ce serait comme à l'ordinaire
les travailleurs qui en ferait les frais
voilà pourquoi mon appel doit être
entendu et que chacun mesure ses
responsabilités certes il est fort
compréhensible que des revendications se
fasse jour notamment au sujet des
conditions de travail et il est vrai que
depuis six mois des événements retarder
l'examen de ces questions est loin de
moi l'idée de prendre prétexte de nos
difficultés présentes pour repousser
tout examen et tout commencement de
solution
ce n'est pas en vain que j'ai parlé de
concertation permanente
j'entends par là que le gouvernement est
disposé à écouter à dialoguer à discuter
il existe pour cela des instances
qualifiés dans chaque domaine dans
chaque entreprise
dans ce cadre toutes les questions
peuvent être posées et trouver leurs
réponses dans la mesure compatible avec
l'exigence économique et financière du
moment des calendriers peuvent être
établies pour que ce soit programmé les
mesures à prendre
c'est l'esprit de toutes les décisions
où je viens d'annoncer dans ces
conditions pourquoi avant d'avoir épuisé
les possibilités normal de 10
question pourquoi ces arrêts brusques de
travail insupportables pour les usagers
[Applaudissements]
insupportable pour les usagers est
dommageable pour le progrès des
entreprises elles-mêmes
c'est à dire l'intérêt de leurs agents
je vous le demande
que deviendrait notre pays si chacun
refusé d'observer les règles
élémentaires sans lesquelles il ne peut
exister ni démocratie ni paix civile
ainsi
par exemple le gouvernement ne tolèrera
pas que soit porté atteinte à des
services d'intérêt général tels les
perceptions et les caisses mutuelles
alors que là aussi le dialogue a été
offert est largement pratiqué quand il
s'agit de revendications
professionnelles
le gouvernement a dit il le prouve qu'il
est bien celui de la concertation et du
progrès mais si par contre il s'agit
pour certains de prendre appui sur ses
revendications pour contester et menacé
les autorités démocratiquement élues
alors le gouvernement légitime le
gouvernement de la république sera
prouvé qu'il est là pour défendre la
nation contre toute aventure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]